[Musique]
on commence se résumer avec Valérie PCR
qui sera candidate aux élections
présidentielles de 2022 élu à 60 % des
voix au Congrès les républicains ce
samedi face à Eric sootti la candidate
prépare à présent sa campagne pour
2022 la construction du centre
aqualudique de morpa et lancour se
poursuit la ministre des Sports Roxan
marassine et Anou s'est rendu sur place
pour poser symboliquement la première
pierre des bassins l'ouverture du est
prévu pour septembre 2022 après
plusieurs mois de travaux la centrale de
géothermie de véisie vill coublé a été
mise en service 12000 foyers de la
commune yvelinoise vont pouvoir se
chauffer avec la température du sol
comme chaque année le club climat
énergie de 550 an en Yveline a organiser
sa conférence autour du développement
durable dans l'agglomération l'objectif
établir une stratégie pour les
prochaines années et puis mercredi avait
lieu la première édition des Rencontres
de l'inclusion à hlencour organisé par
la Fondation face le principe et de
mobiliser les entreprises du territoire
en faveur de l'insertion professionnelle
plusieurs dizaines des 130 entreprises
signataires étaient
[Musique]
présentes